let's take our next call at 6 1 7 830
4750 the next caller is from the 203
area code uh who's on the phone and
what's on your mind my name is Chloe and
I'm from Connecticut my question is in a
trump administration water services like
Department of Mental Health I mean
what's not going to look like how much
is he gonna try and cut us and what we
do yeah i've had people at talk to me
about this because they work in
different capacities in heavily
federally funded programs and uh that
you know yeah i think that there's going
to be immediate changes like it from
successfully and you know what I'm gonna
have to I'm have to answer you uh off
air I'm gonna meet you just for a second
because it's so there's such a wind
noise there I think you can still hear
me um there's sort of like the odd more
more low-hanging fruit that will be
impacted by a potential Obamacare repeal
that that sort of layer 1 layer 2 would
be if individual programs that are
funded for example at the Health and
Human Services level or at other levels
of government if whoever is in charge of
those departments which is pretty a
pretty deplorable list of people were
quickly learning uh then you might start
to see funding cut for some of those
programs and I think that that is
probably going to happen uh later I'm
hoping that it won't happen at all i
know in massachusetts there's major
concerns over programs that are state
programs related to the opiate crisis
but they do receive federal funding and
you know Charlie Baker the Republican
Massachusetts governor who is not a
trump guy uh seems you know moderately
committed to continuing those programs
going forward so I think there's no real
answer to that right now Chloe but it's
a very very good question nonetheless